we have one last montage oh you didn't
get to know about secret montage let's
roll that secret montage right now I'd
roll it in the world of video games 18
years is a pretty long time the guitar
hero franchise was only around 45 it's
been just six years since the last
half-life game and Microsoft of only had
skin in the console race for 11 but this
may first gamespot com turns 18 so when
we cast our eyes back at 18 years of
game spotting what memories rise to the
surface well first of all 18 years of
reviewing games of 10 the whole way down
to one I hope we don't get a [ __ ] for
on games that's right
18 years of making video reviews for as
many games as we could for letting
gamers around the world know the best
games to play and suffering through crap
so that you don't have to
18 years of casually dressed people
talking into cameras and telling you
what's wash hi everybody I'm Rochelle
appreciate a catch on the spot in spots
weekly preview show 18 years of
producing shows button-mashing EF ms
reality check and of blazing the trail
with live video where nothing ever goes
wrong you're not gonna believe this but
the fire alarm just went off 18 years of
covering III of packing up trucks full
of gear and taking road trips or friends
than to la of setting up a stage hosting
live shows and transporting millions of
you directly to the show floor 18 years
of covering the news previews tips mods
interviews forums blog posts and
community all in the name of just
hanging out with other people who love
video games so to those of you who have
been part of the gamespot family over
the past 18 years those of you who have
Commons as post-its chatted or just hung
out thanks for reading our reviews
talking about our news and watching our
dumb internet videos thank you for being
part of our community and here's to
another 18
you